في كل خيمه هنا في هناك قصه وهناك حكايه
هناك شهادات عن الزلزال وهناك مفقودين لم
يعد لم يعودوا موجودين مع عائلاتهم انا في
هذه المنطقه قبل قليل وصلت والتقيت بام
احمد وهي لاجئه السوريه كانت تقيم في
اصلاحيتها هدم منزلها تهدم منزلها وفقدت
ثلاثه من ابنائها مع الاسف واحاول الان
ساحاول ان التقي بها واجري مع هذه
المقابله لنستمع الى شهادتها وما جرى معهم
اثناء الزلزال اول شيء ام احمد الباقيه
بحياتكم انا حابب تحكي لي وقت اللي صار
الزلزال انت وين كنتي وشو اللي صار معكم
انا كنت كان وقتها بردو تلج كنت عم بكب
صوت للصوبه
انا وجارتي الله يرحمه
اول هزيت بدي اطلع على الدرج قامت
بعدين ما احسنت اطلع هون انطبق الباب باب
الدار قام بعدين ما في خلال دقيقه مش
للبنايه كلها
ولادي الاربعه وهذا معه
عمرها اربع سنين تصيح يا ماما حدا يحسن
طالع
ومين هن اولادك اللي ماتوا بنتين وصبي
بنتين البنت عمرها 17 سنه وبنت عمرها اربع
سنين والصبي عمره 12 سنه طب ما كان في فرق
انقاذ تيجي تساعدكم او تحاول تطلع اولادك
من تحت الانقار الوقت قطعت الكهرباء
والدنيا ثلج والشاطر ملتهي بعيلته ما اجوا
لبعد يومين
كانت بنتي خالصه البنت الصغيره فطست فطست
جرح ما فيها بس هادوكي قلبت الجسر على
ظهرهم
وعراسه الصبي خلص مع الحارق ماتوا وقتها
الله يرحمهم جميعا ويصبركم خبرتيني بسوريا
الله الله يجزيه الخير يا رب عامر عامر
اليونس كتير ساعدني وقف معي من الاول لاخر
لحظه هلا راح سافر عند عيلته الله ييسر له
زوجك اللي موجود قلتي لي زوجك كان موجود
بسوريا قبل الزلزال مو هيك جوزي راح على
سوريا قبل الزلزال بسبعه ايام راح بدي
اعزي امه ماتت اختي عمرها 22 سنه
بعدين الحمد لله رب العالمين اجا شغلة
ولاده راح ابر اولاده انا وصلت لهم لباب
الهواء انا وعامر اليونس
وصلنا الى باب الهواء اخذوه من اخدوه مني
اهلي واهله
ابرون هونيك انا ما بعرف هيك
زوجك هلا وين ما بعرف هو بادلب قالوا لي
انه سوى حادث بس ما بعرف شيء عنه بعد ما
دفن بعد ما دفن الاولاد ما حدا خبرني شي
عنه يعطيني وعم ننتظر فرج الله
الله يخلي لك اياه ويا رب يعني يكون سند
لالك وسند لزوجك ان شاء الله يا رب تلتقوا
عن جديد وان شاء الله يعني مثل ما بيقولوا
يعني ما في كلمات توصف الماسه ان شاء الله
يا رب اخر المصايب ويكون ابنك هو قره عين
لالك ويكون سند لالك ولعبوه وان شاء الله
قريبا تلتقي مع زوجك ان شاء الله شكرا
كتير لالك كنت معنا على قناه العربيه شكرا
لحضرتك كثير